dubai mitten im deutschen dauer shutdown
posten viele deutsche urlauberinnen und
in fernseh rennen anfang des jahres
sehnsuchts post aus den vereinigten
arabischen emiraten ist hagelt kritik
und dann kommt jan böhmermann mit seinem
dubai beitrag der im netz noch mehr
wellen schlägt influence erinnern wie
fiona erdmann würden nicht nur das
luxusleben genießen sondern sie seien
auch von einem absolutistischen
herrscher gekauft und damit machbar asta
lamo aleikum und herzlich willkommen zu
dieser folge von training diesmal direkt
aus den vereinigten arabischen emiraten
in dubai warum zieht es hier so viele
influenza hin und was deren geschichten
dahinter
das werden wir herausfinden das ist
victoria sonntag model und in kürzeren
sie ist 24 und die zeit sechs monaten
hier in dubai
sie ist die freundin eines erfolgreichen
basketballer der verdient genug geld für
beide aber sie will sich hier trotzdem
etwas eigenes aufbauen
ich treffe sie auf einer yacht mit ihrer
freundin merle will sie fotos zu ihren
instagram account machen da hat sie
zwölf tausend follower in viel juti
produkte und postet bilder aus ihrem
leben in dubai 12.000 ist ganz gut aber
da geht noch mehr
daher das shooting weiter sie gibt mir
eine kleine tour
diesmal beeindruckt ihre freundin merle
ist flugbegleiterin und lebt auch in
dubai hier vernetzt sich die deutsche
community ziemlich schnell
die beiden geben hier ein paar tipps wie
man den gute influenza fotos macht
das jährigen liste
und dahinter das
ob am ende erfolgreiche bilder für ihren
account und auch für meine instagram
dabei waren schauen wir später erst
einmal will ich raus aus dem luxus der
reichen und schönen und die andere seite
der stadt kennenlernen nur wenige
kilometer von den glamour finden
entfernt sieht es nämlich nicht mehr so
luxuriös aus hier leben vor allem
menschen mit asiatischen und
afrikanischen wurzeln
viele sind arbeitsmigrantinnen gekommen
aus armut was ist ihre geschichte dazu
später mehr
denn ich werde alles daran setzen auch
einen diese arbeiter zu treffen und
migrantinnen wäre dubai nicht das was es
heute ist vor 70 jahren war hier noch
brachland dubai bestand von ihm nicht
auslöste ein unbedeutendes fischerdorf
nicht zuletzt das öl hat den rasanten
aufstieg dieses emirats möglich gemacht
es sind die ausländischen arbeitskräfte
die für einen hungerlohn schuften und
die für den aufbau der luxuswelt
ausgeweitet werden und wurden
mittlerweile sind dubai sowie die
gesamten vereinigten arabischen emirate
eine industrie nation und eine der
reichsten staaten der welt
[Musik]
ich bin mit einem newcomer endloser
verabredet der in dubai die chance für
einen neuanfang sucht
der mal bereitet gerade seine trainings
session vor er ist 24 und 2009/10 von
düsseldorf ii her gezogen nachdem er
unter einer starken depression wird das
zeigt mir ausschnitte von damals auf
seinem englischsprachigen youtube können
wo ist deine der beton ist ja mal wir
hier großer sportlichen flitzer werden
und von seinem fitness trainings leben
das war nicht immer so das ist eine sehr
traurige geschichte war als ich
hingekommen bin damals 2009 10 mit 23
jahren ich bin gekommen und ich wollte
dieses bootcamp starb
und dann habe ich auch einige zusagen
bekommen war 17.18 uhr ich habe auf die
leute gewartet dann kamen die ersten
nachrichten ich schaffe es nicht ich
kann nicht kommen dann sah sich möglich
da allein und marktfelder leine im
training es war am anfang die ersten
drei mal kam keiner zu mir ins training
das war wirklich ein rückschlag den ich
erst mal so einstecken musste ob er
heute mehr glück hat und die leute
kommen sie mal hat in deutschland alles
aufgegeben um es hier zu schaffen so
dass hier noch vor dass die leute alle
noch mal so
weil es noch nicht ja das ist ja mal ein
bisschen ganz komisch also die meisten
leute kommen ja damals auf den letzten
drücker also gegen 659 man streiche man
meist stehe ich immer weil es hier
schreiben ein bisschen rum kommt das
kennen die meisten kommen dann immer so
gegen 6 55 60 neunten also wirklich
allerletzten drücker aber okay wir
starten erst möglich so gegen sieben uhr
7 1 7 und 2 grad
wir haben jetzt 62 53 und tatsächlich
langsam kommen die ersten mittlerweile
hat ja mal ein paar dutzende kundinnen
wie mehrere wochen abonniert haben und
ihn dafür regelmäßig geld überweisen
die akquise läuft über instagram und co
normales mit einem touristenvisum nach
dubai gekommen musste dann sein sport
gewerbe anmelden und konnte loslegen
er ist sich sicher in deutschland hätte
er das so einfach niemals machen können
und weil ich in der korona zeit auch ein
bisschen zugenommen habe nehme ich das
training gerne mehr
kunden von hotelplan bei der herz und
charme verleiht
die karosserie ist er nicht der russe
jemal macht daher gerade noch sehen ich
mache auch noch mit diesen märkten
schweiz auch ein bisschen er meist ja
irgendwie das wetter hier ist einfach
ein riesen faktor wie sieht's mit eur
psychischen gesundheit aus spielt für
euch das wetter eine rolle
könnt ihr es im kalten gut aushalten
oder nicht schreibt mir das einfach in
die kommentare
die dubai leben menschen jeder
vorstellbaren nationalität das merkt man
auf einer kundschaft von jamal bist du
weißt attraktiv für viele deutsche ich
denke es ist einfach das gute wetter das
lockere leben das den ganzen entspannte
lifestyle sage ich mal arbeiten
steuerfrei
das klima für tribologie bei halo 2
displays dass man in einer weise weiß
geschichte place konnte die vereinigten
arabischen emirate sind eine
einwanderungsstadt nur knapp elf prozent
der bevölkerung sind emiratische
staatsbürger innen alle anderen kommen
aus dem ausland
scheich mohammed bin raschid al maktoum
führt das emirat dubai absolutistisch
ein parlament gibt es nicht strenge
regeln und einschränkungen der
meinungsfreiheit sind an der
tagesordnung viele leben in angst vor
den harten strafen
zur erinnerung der scheich hat wohl
seine eigene tochter gefangen
trotzdem gelingt es dem emirat
unglaublich viele arbeitsmigrantinnen
anzulocken
grund ist die unkomplizierte
einwanderungs bürokratie ein
arbeitsvisum kriegt man oft nur in
wenigen wochen und steuerlich soll es
super attraktiv sein wie genau sieht das
hier aus wenn zb ich als influenza
durchstarten wollte
ich treffe jemanden der es wissen muss
rastafari ist steuerberater und lebt
hier seit 13 jahren
er berät viele influenza innen und
deutsche kleinen unternehmer innen die
nach dubai ausgewandert sind und ist
selbst deutscher und ist spezialisiert
auf emirates und deutsche steuerrecht
hier in dubai oder im vorjahr gibt es
keine besteuerungen allem auch
unternehmensgewinne oder auf einkommen
es gibt auch keine capital games text
das heißt eine besteuerung von
veräußerungsgewinnen das heißt sie haben
hier aus unternehmerischer sicht
eigentlich ein keine steuerbelastung
eine sehr hohe steuerbelastung
ich frage ihn was es mit dieser
influenza lizenz auf sich hat die bilder
mann in seinem satire clip gezeigt hat
nur werden diese wer diese staatliche
influenza lizenz hat darf in dubai
wohnen leben und influenza
es gibt diese lizenz diese lizenz wie
sie aussieht ich glaube es braucht man
nur zu vergrößern
aber juristisch ist es die erlaubnis
hier gewisse tätigkeiten und zwar die
influenza lizenz auszuüben und sie ist
auch die grundlage dafür dass man hier
in dubai an residenz visumantrag und
hier dann auch als sozusagen als legaler
liga elian dich aufhalten darf an die
gesetze des landes halten muss man sich
anderswo auch der große unterschied ist
aber welche gesetze die vereinigten
arabischen emirate sind ein
absolutistisches regime
und dieses system akzeptiert man quasi
mit wenn man hier in dubai lebt und ein
gewerbe anmelden
also ich halte fest man kann hier sehr
sehr schnell so einen aufenthalt
bekommen und dann hier durch das
influenza sie nicht mehr das glaube ich
nicht so wirklich was aber seht ihr das
anders schreibt mir das in die
kommentare
zurück bei internen victoria sonntag
diesmal treffen wir sie mit der
ehemaligen germany's next topmodel
kandidatin und der 155 tausend follower
starken giuliana fall in einem penthouse
im gefühlt 165 stockwerk
si
[Musik]
wir haben bis nach dubai ich bin ich
hier ja bei blizz sonne
hier ist es war und ich krieg jetzt
megahertz wagen zog es so etwas auch für
mich tun weil es ist einfach hier ist
zwar hier ist toll ich brauch eigentlich
nur sonne sonne strahlend cocktail waren
die fotos die wir auf der yacht
geschossen haben auch post würdig ich
habe noch nicht bearbeitet oder so aber
ich habe ein paar verriet ausgewählt und
mach ich das immer um dann auch zu
wissen ja die anderen 80.000 kann ich
vielleicht auch zeit dass du meine
bilder
ich habe tatsächlich auch ein foto auf
der jagd auf meinem instagram account
gepostet das kam ganz gut an
ein paar fakten ist allerdings auch dann
eben auch influenza innen wie victoria
die hier leben kriegen nicht nur seitdem
böhmermann clip kritik ab also das ist
videor ausgaben auch zum thema
menschenrechte und so hier habe ich auch
bei nachrichten bekommen
ich meine es ist aber auch ein
unterschied finde ich also ich bin ja
jetzt nicht her gezogen weil auch ich
muss jetzt doch dubai live ist so geil
ich meine ich bin wegen meines freundes
hergeben bin natürlich super happy
darüber
deswegen ist es natürlich auch um
content zu kreieren oder einfach sein
interessantes lebenszeit ist hinter
schon place to be quasi ich glaube jedes
land hat dreck am stecken klar ist
stelle ich jetzt echt mies was da abgeht
aber nur weil ich jetzt hier lebe heißt
das nicht dass ich das so unterstütze es
war natürlich eine schlimme sache
im endeffekt finde es gut dass darüber
geredet wird weil sonst kennt man doch
alles ist toll und toll und hier und da
aber es ist im endeffekt effect welt
definitiv sehr viele oberflächlichkeit
hier
klar auf den ersten blick ist dubai
backing amazing alles blitzblank wie in
disneyland victoria und all die anderen
beauty influenza innenleben hier in
einer glamour blase fernab von den
problemen dieser standard dafür werden
sie gerade heftig kritisiert und genau
diese kritik macht es mir so schwer
überhaupt einen der ganz großen
influenza innen vor die kamera zu
bekommen
eine absage bekommen und dann hieß es
jetzt eigentlich voll gerne richtig cool
aber ist einfach gerade gut keine gute
zeit weil die leute viel zu kritisch
sind weil die leute zu hause in der
kälte mit corona sind dann kommt das
nicht gut und es ist richtig schwer
gerade irgendwie diese großen influenza
zu bekommen am ende gelingt es mir doch
lifestyle influenza in fiona erdmann mit
fetten 265.000 followers sagt mir
spontan für ein interview zu wir treffen
uns in einem hotelzimmer an seite des
managements keine kritischen fragen zu
ihrem leben in dubai
fiona erzählt mir dass auch sie für
einen neuanfang her gekommen ist und
zwar schon 2018 dem gar nicht dekadent
ausnahme wie lebst du meine mutter ist
2016 verstorben
ich bin dann in das haus von meiner
mutter gezogen um dort alles sozusagen
ja den ganzen nachlass zu regeln und
während ich dann dort in ihrem haus war
ist dann mein mann verstorben
und das war halt wirklich eine richtig
café zeit ende 2016 hat mich eine
freundin die hier in dubai gelebt hat
gefragt ob ich sie nicht mehr besuchen
kommen möchte und dann bin ich hierher
gekommen und ich hatte hier wirklich das
gefühl mich richtig so ja ich habe mich
hier richtig zu hause gefühlt
ich wusste und das schwöre ich bei
meiner mutter ich wusste nicht einmal
dass man hier keine steuern zahlen muss
das waren wir gar nicht bewusst
erst als ich mal wieder gemacht habe und
ich all die ganzen steps durchlaufen bin
die man so war ihr bad ist gar nicht
bewusst und jeder der mir unterstellen
würde ich bin nach dubai ausgewandert
wegen steuern also sorry
der soll sich mal meine geschichte
anhören fiona postiert dubai post auf
ihrem kanal rolle teatime mit dem baby
ist eines davon
dabei bewirbt die windel marken oder
klamotten und kassiert dafür geld soweit
eigentlich ganz normales influencer
business aber ob absicht oder nicht sie
hat mit ihrem viertel millionen follower
innen auf insta eine große reichweite in
deutschland aufgebaut und endeavour
vergoldet da sich hier keine
steuerabgaben hat fiona betont aber
gekaufte propaganda post sei sie nicht
mehr schreibt keiner und das kann ich
mit gutem gewissen vor was ich zu machen
habe mir schreibt überhaupt keiner vor
ich habe mit niemandem ein vertrag ich
bekomme von niemandem geld wenn man mir
sagt ja warum berichtet du denn die
ganze zeit über dubai und so positiv
dann sage ich okay weil ich jetzt über
köln wohl ewig denn in dubai die kritik
an influenza innen wie fiona erdmann ist
spätestens seit jan böhmermann auf dem
tisch sie kassiert seitdem sehr krasse
kommentare das nächste war ich hoffe du
wirst
ich hoffe du wirst vergewaltigt
verhaftet und dann gefoltert und getötet
das glaube ich war somit eines der
heftigsten sachen und dann dachte ich so
kann bleibt influenza innen in dubai
profitieren von deutsche reichweite ohne
deutsche steuern zahlen zu müssen
und mit der kritik daran muss man leben
klar ist aber auch im job profil von
lifestyle und glamour entführen zu
erinnen steht nicht sich politisch zu
äußern und menschenrechtsverletzungen
anzuprangern
für mich als journalist sieht das
natürlich anders aus ich will gerade
auch die seiten zeigen die hier nicht
zum offiziellen bild gehören und meine
hartnäckigkeit könnte sich auszahlen
ich suche im netz nach kontakten und
frage immer wieder taxifahrer selbst
migranten ob sie arbeiter kennen sie mit
mir reden würden ich bekomme tatsächlich
eine whatsapp nummer der kontakt will
anonym bleiben damit ihm nichts passiert
ich nenne ihnen hier verschieben um ihn
zu sprechen muss sich mit der metro weit
rausfahren und eine andere gegend der
stadt sie heisst diarra
ich packe mein handy aus und filme
verdecken sie zeigt mir wo er wohnt eine
massen unterkunft krass hier sind
plumpsklos stockbetten zehn männer in
einem raum und alle müde von der arbeit
fühlt sich an wie ein gefängnis
rashid es 29 und ist vor zwei jahren
nach rübergekommen er will mir alles
erzählen aber nicht hier
wir gehen in ein lokal er besteht darauf
mich einzuladen das angebot nehme ich
natürlich nicht kann
das leben hier für mich ist sehr hart
ich leide wirklich extrem und fühle mich
oft erniedrigt ich arbeite für eine
fabrik wo wir fenster herstellen das
müssen wir jeden tag in der brütenden
sonne machen
ich lebe hier in einem kleinen zimmer
mit acht anderen ich habe überhaupt
keine privatsphäre und sie haben einen
reisepass rashid kommt aus einem land in
südasien oder afrika wie die meisten
hier bei sich zu hause war er schreiner
hatte eine werkstatt und hat viel besser
gelebt ich frage ihn was er erwartet hat
von dubai ich hatte eine ganz andere
vorstellung als ich noch in meinem land
waren
mir wurde gesagt dass ich meine
fähigkeiten anwenden kann
und ich dachte ich werde nur einen tag
in so einer unterkunft sein und dann in
einem anständigen hotel wohnen rashid
verdient nur umgerechnet 300 euro pro
monat
seine geschichte zu hören bricht mir das
herz ausbeutung von arbeitsmigrantinnen
gibt es aber auch direkt bei uns in
europa ich habe es als reporter selbst
gesehen was ist also der unterschied zu
dubai wolfgang jüttner von human rights
watch ordnet ein als sicherlich auch in
europa gibt es katastrophale schlechte
bedingungen für für arbeiter wenn man
sich die lage auf wie vielen in
obstplantagen beispielsweise ansieht
oder auch natürlich in deutschland die
situation in den in den schlachthöfen
der fleischverarbeitung beziehungsweise
auch bei in der landwirtschaft da darf
man auch keinen nicht darüber hinweg
gehen und das muss auch angegangen
werden
der große unterschied ist allerdings
dass in den in den europäischen ländern
die rechtliche lage im internationalen
normen in der regel entspricht und dass
vor allen dingen auch die kritiken an
solchen bedingungen in der
öffentlichkeit aufgegriffen werden kann
und das ist eben jeden fall aber in den
vereinigten arabischen emiraten schwer
möglich weil er die meinungsfreiheit
sehr eingeschränkt ist und dadurch
jegliche kritik auch oft als gleich eine
kritik an dem herrscherhaus
betrachtet wird diese stadt wirkt auf
mich schon irgendwie wie eine fassade
hinter die niemand so richtig blicken
sollen für leute wie übersteht einen
gefängnisneubau ausbeuterischer arbeit
für menschen die jamal aber ein ort
voller chancen so das war es auch schon
wieder mit dieser folge von trending ich
hoffe sie hat euch gefallen
die könnte ich noch andere folgen von
uns angucken ansonsten möchte ich euch
noch meine kommentare dazu aufrufen
mitzudiskutieren
wie sieht ihr das ganze haltet edition
ordnung dass die leute hier die
influenza sind ihre träume und wünsche
erfüllen lass dir unternehmerische
vorteile genießen auch wenn es diese
herbe vorwürfe und diese krasse kritik
gibt oder ist es für euch ein absolutes
no go ich schreibe es in die kommentare
und wir sehen uns am nächsten film